my NFL Network analyst compadre
certainly this time of year every single
thing that he says gets picked apart and
listened to he is Daniel Jeremiah good
to see you sir how you doing bud
it's gonna be fun we first saw each
other just moments ago cuz so many of
these kids that are gonna be picked in
the top ten are our bold-faced names
from Saturday you've heard of all these
guys you pretty much have name-brand
programs name-brand players they've all
played in big games on big stage so
everybody's familiar with them and that
means everybody is entrenched with an
opinion a strong opinion one way or the
other it's gonna be fun right miss soon
as I and as I said now our number one as
soon as I saw Rose Donald follow Rosen I
immediately called you if you notice
that I called you right away I'm like
you got to come in and the Honda inside
a rapport with Daniel Jeremiah starts
right here and right now
look answer the poll question who do you
think what do you think the brown should
do first overall with those three
choices well look it those are the three
choices right yeah I think so I think
when you look at it to me Berkeley is
the best player in the draft they have
to take a quarterback no question if you
if you want to cross your fingers and
hope that maybe there's a run on
quarterbacks you could see Berkeley at
four if you want to trade back in which
they could easily probably have to go up
one spot which remember they did it a
long time ago with Kellen Winslow moving
up one spot for him there's some
precedent there they have so many picks
I think they could still get the best
player in the draft as well as the
quarterback but they have to go
quarterback first and for me it really
comes down to to Josh Rosen and Sam darn
'old I I lean right now more towards
Donald why then I do to Rosen a couple
things that number one I've seen darn
'old do things that Rosen can't do in
terms of getting out of some trouble
when you watch him the I don't know if
people understand this us the offensive
line rich was terrible I was at that
Cotton Bowl he got hit repeatedly each
and every play and you go back and watch
the cut-ups of third and 6-plus throws I
saw a lot more pressure on Donald than I
did on Rosen and Donnell can get away
from some of that he can survive and get
outside of that he can make every throw
the turnovers you got a you got a sort
through that Rosen if you just want a
pure passer where they are right now
stepping day one
Rosen's ahead but his kind of inability
to create once things you get a free
rusher which you're gonna see each and
every Sunday that to me is my hang up
there with rose so you're saying Rosen's
more of the pocket pass you're a pocket
passer no question he he's a decent
athlete when he takes off you can go get
you some yards but just being able to
maneuver and make that free rush or miss
Donald's on another level with me and I
think Darnell can evolve and grow into
being the passer that Rosen is right now
now my concern watching that Cotton Bowl
yep okay was that I understand the
offensive line was bad yeah but I mean
that front seven at Ohio State I'm sorry
that the Ohio State brought um with
Schiano
yeah dialing it up I mean that's you
just kind of saw what Donald's gonna see
on Sundays this fall and not only was
that difficult for him to handle
protection wise looked like he couldn't
figure out what what was coming his way
at all but when it came time and score
fast are you even you even said you know
that that where's the tempo on the side
that's a coaching thing to me I did not
understand and then I responded to you
by saying well there is a tempo of him
getting to the line looking over waiting
20 seconds looking one more time and
saying hike that that wasn't it that's
not a concern for wasn't evaluating me I
think almost maybe some of that was the
reason why I ended up coming out I don't
know I thought for sure year two with
what he did last year they would give
him the keys to the car a little bit
more which they clearly didn't I mean
you're down three scores in that game
and there's such a slow pace he's
looking to the sidelines I wish they
would have put the game more in his
hands that's another top I mean that
whole game is a is a long discussion
when I went back and while I was at the
game when I went back and watched it
rich their interior three offensive line
just got crushed
he had pressure up the middle on him all
game long and I can pull out 12 to 15
throws he made in that game as
impressive as you'll ever see threw for
350 yards they just got down the red
zone it and bogged down it wasn't like
they couldn't move the football to me
the biggest issue was Sam as the fumbles
and to me there's some some coachable
things on there his offhand comes off
the ball a lot inside the pocket you can
coach that you can get better there and
I think some people look at the broad
number of fumbles
when I sort it and what you can do with
technology is great and I can watch all
these fumbles some of them are on the
mesh on his own read like that's not you
know he is that the running back is at
the quarterback one of them's on a
lateral back it's a swing pass to Ronald
Jones he drops the ball he doesn't fall
on it that goes in Sam Donald's turnover
category so I think he can clean up the
things he needs to clean up his ability
you watch him against Washington against
those three NFL DBS we talked about in
the draft last year he tore them up the
big stage with the Rose Bowl he tore up
Penn State Texas this year when they had
to make plays late in the game he did it
so I've seen him do it I know he can do
it so when it's all said and done
Daniel Jeremiah here in the Honda inside
a report on the Rich Eisen show you have
no problem with him coming out no I mean
look you can make it I can make a case
he can go back he can work on some of
those things that you talked about
footwork wise protecting the football
but I also think you go to the next
level you put him with an NFL coach
who's gonna scheme around his ability
his Hugh Jackson that coach I think he'd
be a good fit in that system you do I
mean I think he's a super sized better
version of Andy Dalton and we saw Andy
Dalton have tremendous success under
huge acts he's a much better more
talented player than Andy Dalton but has
some of that movement ability that he
would like what about the idea that I've
been positing on Twitter and on this
show that the Browns take Darnell did
one if that's their quarterback and then
with all the pics that Shashi Brown and
Jonah Hill and all those people left
over they call up Dave Kettleman and
make him the offer he can't refuse and
say drop down a four and take all these
other picks and we move up to two and
gets a qualm barkley do you think that's
feasible I think that wouldn't happen I
don't even think they'd have to go to
two though why because I think the
Giants this is when you look at it from
a giant's standpoint this is a team with
multiple Super Bowls there's a lot of
pride inside that organization Dave
gentlemen was there during those years
and having been look you haven't been in
my time in Baltimore where we had our
expectations and what we expected your
and they're viewing this year as a
complete aberration they're now in their
mind they're saying we're never gonna be
picking up here ever again we have to
get our quarterback for when Eli's done
right now they have I be shocked if the
Giants do not take a quarterback at
which means Indianapolis there at 3:00
is the landing spot for the running back
and when you look at how bad that roster
is in a young GM and a new coach coming
in I think they'd be a prime candidate
to say hey we'll we'll slide back one
spot and give us some extra picks well
so if if if the if the oh okay so if the
Giants did do this trade anyway though
yeah then wouldn't the Colts go ahead
and but with the Colts then trade out
for whoever wanted Rosen is that what
you're saying I mean just we're gonna
find out what the Colts philosophy is at
the running back position because some
teams are gonna look at Gurley and for
net and the success they've had said
Zeke - exactly we can take a premier
running back right now and other teams
gonna look and say who led the league in
rushing this year Kareem hunt I can find
this bring this draft is loaded into
position so who's that at loaded at the
position at quarterback who could be in
that second round pick that that teams
can sort of wait and choose somebody
else top five top ten well I think you
think I think you've got four
quarterbacks that are separate from
everybody else when you look at we've
talked about Darnell we've talked about
Rosen Josh Allen is gonna go way up
there supremely talented the highest
ceiling of any of these guys he went to
point oh I don't think he's as polished
as a passer as whence was coming out
okay he's got it's crazy that he's got
more upside wits weights is the MVP of
the league if he's healthy yeah you've
looked at Josh Allen has a stronger arm
he's even a better athlete as good as
we've seen carson wentz as an athlete
he's bigger he's just went is more
polished and more poised and you know
what you're getting when's his floor
coming out was much higher than Josh
Allen's huh
Josh Allen has rare rare rare rare tools
but to me that's why I look at the
Giants MA and I know some people think
that's too early for Josh Allen I think
it could be a perfect thing for him
because you've got Eli Manning for the
next couple years you don't have to plan
he's built to play in that so when's 2.0
against Wentz 1.0 could be the same to
go in that and any accuracy issues with
him you know what he's he's unique
because he's more accurate when he
really drives the ball like especially
outside the numbers yeah and that's kind
of unique at the college level the touch
is something he can he can work on work
in the middle field so Mayfield's the
fourth quarterback in Mayfield is the
wild card it's kind of the four I think
all four of those guys
gonna be long gone early early I think
how how high well you just look at the
number it's supply and demand I mean I
know
Brockman was talking about Kirk Cousins
and you know where he lands maybe one of
these teams is where he lands like Smith
is gonna be available yes there's a
couple dominoes that could fall there
but there's still more teams in need
then you look at the supply oh yeah Oh
for those guys I think which team do you
think that his quarterback needy top ten
might go in that cousins or Alex Smith
direction what is the scouting community
think on that front first blush top of
January well I mean I I don't know I
think given your druthers I think most
teams would rather go with a young guy
just because a it's cheaper and you've
got a chance for the longevity factor
having a lot longer and that's gonna be
it's it's it's gonna be tricky to see
where those guys would openly end up I
still think the Jets are they the other
thing you say maybe the Jets are a
little bit shy of being aggressive and
going they've you know tried to roll out
some young quarterbacks hasn't worked
maybe they would come on hold on a
second if the Jets are gun shy of Baker
Mayfield because if Christian Hackenberg
I will absolutely I I might go to the
bathroom in my suit on the set of hanif
elephants on the NFL Network like that's
I don't know that's good it might be
good for ratings it's not gonna be good
from I'm too close to you next to me
this time around but no all those guys
then to me there's that second tier
that's when you get to the Mason
Rudolph's to Luke Fox we'll see under
Jackson we don't know if he's coming out
I'm still waiting okay and ice to be
truthful I still you do a lot of work on
on the more Jackson alright let's take a
break here that's the Honda insider
report again brought to you by the
all-new Honda Accord whether you're
headed to the stadium or just running
out for snacks the Accord gets you there
in comfort and style with a
sophisticated redesign and high-tech
features like standard Honda sense in
the all-new Accord is the most
impressive Honda ever I want to get a
little bit more into what we're talking
about for the draft you will be I assume
at the national championship game gonna
be there Monday night okay very good you
were at the Rose Bowl you were at the
Cotton Bowl and want to hit on some of
them other things that you've seen in
how how you uh you stand on the national
championship game coming up right now as
well as
more good stuff with Daniel Jeremiah
that is next here on the Rich Eisen show
DIRECTV's audience networks going to
give you a chance to go back to school
with a timely sports special big man on
campus that features four legends from
each of the bcs playoff teams returning
to their campus as the school prepares
for the big games we followed Tajh Boyd
Jason White garrison Hearst and Greg
McElroy in this ESPN produced piece big
man on campus Friday night at 8:00 p.m.
on DIRECTV's audience Network channel
239 and on DirecTV now if you Daniel
Jeremiah second segment with with the
NFL Network analyst and longtime Scout
in the NFL who had the best game on
national championship semifinal New
Year's Day you'd choose one it was the
best I probably go Sony Michelle he was
one of my favorite players to watch even
before coming into that game I went on a
little swing so I saw the Cotton Bowl
the Fiesta Bowl the second was on
another level
Evita veía from Washington by the way
that you talk about a freak show I saw
that game rich he's 340 pounds he's a
Haloti 2.0 he's more athletic than hell
OD he has a tackle on punt the 340 pound
man breaking down in space and making a
tackle on a punt so there's some some
premier players let's let's linger a
little bit on the the SE Quan Barclay
man love here what
where does he rank on the prospect
I've run him back coming out of college
from what you have seen over your entire
your entire scouting career well one of
my Adrian was one of my early years so I
think Bush was actually the year before
him okay I think I've told you this
before Reggie Bush is the highest grade
I've ever given anybody now in hindsight
it's too high too high of a grade but I
think I put a ginormous grade on Reggie
but then after Reggie then was Adrian
Peterson Adrian Peterson is the unique
he's a unicorn just I've never seen me
with that explosive power that he has
and not sense that I haven't seen
anything like that not in say Kwan
doesn't have that but in terms of just
an all-around running back I'd puts a
Kwan right underneath Adrian Peterson
and I I'm look I love Ezekiel Elliott
I love Leonard fournette
todd gurley huge great on those guys and
I think this kid can be better he's a
piece of he's a special player well what
what makes him so special do you think
that jumps out of his he's the way I
said this to Bucky the other day and it
sounds crazy when you say it but I
really believe it everything that you've
seen Alvin Kamara do on an NFL field in
terms of making people miss running away
from people being used in the past game
he's been using the return game running
the football say qualms Barkley can do
all those same things he's 230 pounds oh
my god he's gonna run in the low four
threes he's gonna jump through the roof
so he's an athletic freak and then just
his lateral change of direction all that
stuff I know some people will say well I
only had this many hundred yard games
don't don't let don't let that bother
you with what was in front of him and
what teams were trying to take away you
know so it led to some of the limited
production he's a rare rare rare rare
dude yeah and so again Browns still go
quarterback one right you have two
quarterback league man I mean and part
of the sake one thing I've seen him play
twice live tons of tape but so play in
the Rose Bowl last year mmm pretty good
yes I saw him in the Fiesta Bowl this
year I mean he was he's a freak and you
said his lower body reminds you of who
well I mean I was around Jamal Lewis
with the Ravens he's got Jamal's lower
half which is ginormous and he's you
know over six feet tall so he's a much
taller version that's crazy tackle that
guy you don't cuz he jumps over you
because he only runs past you too
don't forget that oh and by the way he's
have you don't have you visited with him
I have not look forward to meeting
ridiculously intelligent incredible kid
we talked with James Franklin before the
season I mean everything he just check
check check check and out of the
backfield he catches he you can line him
up in the slot and also this two he
blocks yes he's Zeke was of was not as
good but he's right there well he's
smart enough to know what's what and get
better at that exactly and he's also
smart enough to know that that's what
keeps him on the field on third down in
the NFL he's I mean I think he's I the
can't-miss thing is scary you never say
it but he's right all right so let's get
into the weeds a little bit more senior
bowl did the brown that the Browns
refused to go or did the scouting
community refused to let the Browns do
it again because everything I hear is
that some of those practices helped
nobody yeah I want to get air dirty
scouting over here you always wanted the
practices you always want to be run from
an evaluation standpoint and they're not
just can they learn all the verbage
we're gonna throw at him going through
walkthroughs to make sure guys now we
want to get tons of reps so you can
evaluate these guys right didn't really
get that I don't know the the what went
into the decision of who is gonna coach
it but I do know that the Denver Broncos
being in this game and with Baker being
there and I do believe Josh Allen will
end up going there I think he's gonna be
able to graduate early so if I'm the
Broncos I'm lobbying to get both those
kids on your team so you can get your
hands on them for a whole week your
rights how fun this is gonna be rich
we've got quarterbacks we've got
big-time running backs defensive linemen
it's funny how it gonna be how this
works guys because he's like you know
how fun this is gonna be and when you
said the Broncos can get Mayfield and
Allen on their hands I thought this the
Jets what well look they did find some
really good players yes okay who despite
the noise like what I just made played
very well okay and the coach showed that
he can he can coach and that kid Adams
is a real thumper she's too young say
and Adams okay but they got they have to
get the triggerman six overall they must
they have to
there's no come on I don't want to hear
about a guard I don't hear about a
tackle I don't hear about any that stuff
they have to write will be what's their
come on now what's gonna be there at six
pace ourselves rich this is a marathon
maybe this is not a 400-meter do you
think do you think do you think Elway
would fall in love with Kirk Cousins
well what do you think Shanahan's
whispering in his little quarterbacks
ear don't forget I was wonder drafting
him I know what he can do you you love
my system
you wanted my system that's the guy can
run your sister
I was at the Cotton Bowl watch sam
donaldson right in front of me and this
seat was John Elway next to him was Gary
Kubiak next to him was Matt Russell who
runs their personnel department all
three of them there they all were at
that game
they all went I don't think I don't know
if Kubiak wasn't there but you had John
Elway and and Matt Russell at the
wyoming game to watch Josh Allen so so
there he's given some look-see
personally yeah and now I guess they
might get a chance to coach those those
kids at the Senior Bowl so it's not
great not great news for Paxton Lynch so
then so then he got a shot yeah he had a
shot right well he might beg to differ
but so who is that quarterback that
could be taken at the top of the second
round
I think Mason Rudolph's a guy that a lot
of people were intrigued by mmm at
Oklahoma State he's big he kind of
reminds me he's a little bit like Kirk
Cousins you know I think you get him in
the right spot you can you could have
something there and what do you where do
you stand on the national championship
game of Georgia versus Alabama how do
you think that's gonna play I've watched
tons of tape on him I was at that Rose
Bowl and saw George I just think when
does Alabama lose street fights
that's Georgia is gonna want to come out
there and run it down your throat and
Alabama is so big and strong up front
they don't lose those type type of games
they're more if Oklahoma woulda got to
that game I think Alabama would have
been a little more vulnerable they just
you getting a phone booth they don't
they don't lose those games that kid
Fromme was spectacular poised huh my god
I could not believe he was in high
school the year before nice and poised
oh maybe maybe he can wing it around a
little bit yeah that's uh that's not
Oklahoma's defense he's playing this
week though rich how many do you see
some of the lanes that those guys were
running dude I saw Toronto Payne pick
one off to set up his own touchdown
catch and by the way go down to the
ground like Calvin Johnson even put the
ball down on the ground but I held on to
it yeah what do you survive the ground
he survived the ground speaking of hand
size whose hand size are let's get whose
hand size we've been talking about at
the combine well anytime you have that
many fumbles McDonnell does the hand
size people will be interested to see
what his hand sizes and you have to
remember first two picks Cleveland and
the Giants bad weather city's bad
the divisions they care about hand-sized
dorsey coming from Green Bay they were
huge huge on hand sites obviously
stopped in Kansas City on the way there
but kind of hit me shouldn't we do the
same combine evaluation for presidential
candidates hand size and Wonderlic
answer lot that Trump is going to the
national championship I saw that
yesterday so I think he's going I have
been to the World Series when Bush was
there at in 2001
you know after 9/11 and it was like
truly Fort Apache the Bronx so you came
at you about the first pick it was
incredible Wow I will never forget it I
was a messy at it but I also know what
it's like when the leader of the free
world comes to a big sporting event so
get there early but get there early in
the AG LMS I get there early hey good
news though hmm
it's a Monday night game chick-fil-a
Trump's having for dinner you think huh
does he lead the SS I can't wait I
assume you'll be able to see him in the
end be part of ESPN's mega cast 60
seconds if you just got a couple more
minutes what I'd like to do is I'm gonna
break down some film oh okay but the
film is Sam darn 'old farewell video
that he tweeted out but off short did I
imagine that all I know is Spielberg
definitely didn't do it for us it's not
great okay that's gonna be coming up
next here on this edition of the Rich
Eisen show we are back in 60 seconds
here on the program alright one more
segment here with Daniel Jeremiah move
the sticks they must follow on Twitter
it was funny when we were going back and
forth Charlie look who is in charge of
all of our like pretty much this time of
year the hang of the spring he's the
king that's one of the most talented
producers that that I've ever worked
with in you as well as soon as Donald
Rosen when he texted me and yeah right
and and he's just he's all fired up he's
all excited and he talked about who do
you say is that the best the cleanest
player well he likes Quintin Nelson at
Notre Dame the guard he loves him right
he loves him and I saw one mock draft
apparently a friend of mine sent me a
jet fans and that's who the Jets are
taken in a mock draft and I'm like don't
worry they are not taking a guard sixth
overall right Charlie right Charlie all
right he's one of the best guards I've
done he's a great player I know but you
had I'm not agreeing with anything no
you had a video that you then texted out
of him missing a block right no no he
pancake pancake but Charlie didn't
interpret it correctly he thought I was
making fun of him I said he's okay
sarcastically like he's more than okay
watch him bury this guy and then Mayock
another tape Brockman they both him and
Mayock had ready to text me out video
well quit Nelson video stored on our
phone just wait oh my gosh
but yeah the Jets aren't choosing an
offensive lineman six overall are they
do I want you to be under such suspense
when they get on the clock I would in
fact if the don't go quarterback because
they're Hackenberg gunshot I was I just
didn't say I would soil myself on
national television I hope you have a
bedpan nearby thank you well so hey now
it depends on what what the first five
pics are doing but I bet you though that
David shall have something incredibly
eloquent to say if you do I guarantee it
you probably have an app for that
now again you said Elway was sitting
right in front of you the gospel yeah
with Kubiak yeah with Kubiak and with
with Russell with Matt Russell okay so
when darn 'old announced he was coming
out yesterday you said was the video cut
off well there's a minute you know
there's only am it was a three minute
long video that he instagrammed out in
three pieces okay so I just saw the
first you just saw the first piece okay
so that said the production value coming
out of USC I gotta be honest with you I
mean this is this is one of the ultimate
film schools
mic del - pho right the annenberg is
probably in the top three easy in the
country period yeah but that's a school
of communication it's not the film
school they both know they're together
they're all tied together by the way
shame on me for ass for asking you about
higher education they want me to go
there I get letters all the time yeah
you're a hundred percent room can you
look up what the film school they would
want her there what do you mean they
want the unification oh they're - they
want me to get a degree from them as a
masters USC School of somatic arts so
darn old's video is their teleprompter
it seemed like he was looking above the
camera but it seemed to us that he
really wasn't speaking freely okay it's
a checklist and so that leads us to the
first ever addition here on the Rich
Eisen show of what were they really
thinking let me interpret this here's a
video number here's the here's the way
that darn olds video started rolling a
Trojan fans this is Sam Donald after
talking to my immediate family very
close friends and many people who have
helped me throughout my life I have made
the decision to declare for the 2018 NFL
Draft
okay so he's looking above the camera
yeah so leads me to think what was he
really thinking and this is what he was
really thinking I also talked to an
agent and determined that the signing
bonus for miles Garrett last year was
just south of 22 million dollars I can
make a little bit more than that this
coming year and drive a Ferrari around
Ohio rather than a ten-speed around
South Central Los Angeles I'm out of
here
roll tape on number two and say coach
Shelton I cannot thank you enough for
believing in a kid from San Clemente
high school with such little game tape
and forgiving me the opportunity and
chance to start at such an incredible
university but if you had only started
me three games sooner we could have been
playing for the national championship
last year what's your evaluation well
the famous Alabama either
but they put a beat Utah so maybe but
you come on now he started against Utah
but having that experience before that
cuz they lost to Stanford maybe they
would have beat Stan through could have
it they would have been playing the
national champions away they were
playing at the end of the year last year
they were rolling okay
roll it's being of rolling here's number
three I want to thank all my teammates
for believing in me as your quarterback
just stick with the process because as
we know the countless hours of workouts
and even studying and staying up late
watching film have really paid off and
are going to pay off in the future well
certainly I'll be more proud to have
been your teammate for three years now
yes even though you let me get sacked
eight times in the Cotton poll but
please keep studying so you don't drop
all those passes what do you think
that's good interpretation and see is he
not just like a super likable dude he is
he is but that ability factors way up
he's way up there and the folks in Ohio
are gonna be wondering what he's really
thinking cuz he's not really telling us
what he's thinking certainly yeah in the
final part of his video thank you to all
the USC family you've been there with us
through thick and thin and have been so
courteous to my family me and my
teammates and coaches USC is going to
continue to rise and continue to build
and win a bunch of championships it was
a good run being the best team in Los
Angeles all these years Wow but now I
will go to the state of Ohio to try and
knock the Rams down a peg so you could
somehow continue being the best team in
Los Angeles but I will be on an Owen 16
team fighting on the only thing I
thought there was a little subliminal
message there which was yes Joe Thomas
please please get healthy and come back
to go to that Monday night booth please
come back Oh articles although there's
like 20 candidates and he's always
thrown about stuff like who's in the
booth that's big I got one name for the
booth next year what do you Tim Tebow
- both stop it stop it what are you
talking about can I make my bold
prediction by Monday night bold
prediction three-man booth and Randy
Moss will be one of the three oh okay
and who are the other two bold I can't
give you that I just give you one just
give me one
Randy Moss in the booth I think you'll
be the three will bring some energy and
and they'll get the kind of an X's and
O's guy maybe a form
what about Aryans and Randy Moss hmm
couple rookies or no but not just let me
just say it this way - it Romo makes it
look easier than it is no question you
can't just come no he didn't I'm
practice games he was great built for it
it's not easy and Aryans it's not easy
it's did to come off you know the podium
just you so Rex gave some of the most
incredible press conferences yeah
entertaining must-see TV and then he
goes in the booth with Beth Moens and
he's just like huh I was a great play
and one thing just at one point in Rex's
game that he did with backbones Smith
was in the game and not one story about
Geno Smith and he started talking up
Geno Smith until Geno had a chance to
play for the Giants and then he talked
him down quick so I was doing the Rams
preseason games this year and Raiders
Rams and they're doing a practice game
so Jim Nantz and Romo in the booth right
next to us I look over
Romo full suit you know looking all to
the nines
Jim Nantz was in like a flowered shirt
and he's like I call Jack Nicklaus and
the Masters in 86 this is nothing for me
and we're almost like D Street but
that's another reason why Romo Romo
treated it very professionally saying
that the guys that you're saying
wouldn't yeah he just makes it look a
lot easier than it is DJ thanks for
coming in okay hopefully first of many
times that we can be a fun spring
looking forward to it and I'm thinking
how are the Jets can screw it up Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience